so Cicero's on the nature of the gods
it's this debate that's taking place
there's a little bit of practice where
sister was telling you about what he's
up to and he's got to get you to the
point where these these people are
actually talking to each other but for
the most part what is it it's a
discussion between these guys who you
can say our friends they're there at
least acquaintances they know each other
one of them is a senator which meant
something pretty important back then all
of them are you know they're all from
the upper class or upper middle class
and they're all top-notch philosophers
so this is a bit different than what you
had with Plato's to have on so this is a
bit different than what you might have
in some other dialogues
this is like having heavy hitters it'd
be like if you brought in you know some
big public intellectuals really know
their stuff but they think very
different things about important matters
when you put one guy over here and
another guy over here and another guy
over here and you say all right go yeah
that's what's actually happening in this
dialogue so it's a very high level of
sophistication there's a lot going on
here there's a lot of information that's
being passed on that's in part a
function of Cicero himself so I want to
tell you a little bit about this guy
Cicero was a Roman politician he
actually left some some advice that has
been used by my political advisors you
know some of the top-notch people yet he
wrote a little piece of electioneering
at one time because one of his friends
petting nephews my event was running for
office but do you want a lot of other
stuff as well
Cicero made his bones as a foreigner as
somebody who would go into a situation
you know whether it be a lot court or
the forum and arguing case and if you
want to argue a case whether but if you
got to do two things
Cicero's book you actually have to know
what you're talking about that really
helps out a lot
right but you also have to be able to
use language well so Cicero wrote a lot
of rhetoric about thinking about how to
order your your mind and your words well
he also was somebody who'd studied
philosophy very extensively he was in
the right place at the right time when
he was a young man in Rome Greek
philosophers were leaving Greece and
coming to Rome and part because Romans
becoming about more important in part
because there were a lot of disorders
happening in Greece and it was nice to
get out of there so he got to study with
some of the big-name representatives of
the important philosophical schools of
his day and just imagine like if you
know Harvard and Yale and all these you
know Ivy League schools there's some
catastrophe and they all came to bears
you know you can study with those
professors right that's sort of what
happened with Cicero then afterwards and
this is what a lot of young Roman men
who had money would do he went and he
traveled you know why do you guys do
study abroad I think what if you had to
do you're supposed to learn something
not just you know hang out in Italy and
have a good time right trying to have a
good time wherever else you go you're
supposed to learn something by travel by
going somewhere else by seeing the world
right Cicero is doing the same thing as
it turned out Cicero spent a lot of time
hanging around philosophies for us both
Athens and Rhodes
so there again he got to me
the great philosophers he comes back he
takes up this you know sort of full-time
Dage and as a being somebody who's
taking part in running the country and
he does that for years and then he's a
contemporary of julius caesar and what
did what are you guys remember about
Julius Caesar rather than approve this
no stamp what else
why was he so important that's how you
that's how he sort of like made his
reputation by conquering call like we
have some you know we've had a few
military generals who became presidents
and they wouldn't become president great
chapel so that was it really on in his
career what else what did he do that was
a fundamental transformation why would
later an emperors called Caesar yeah
exactly
now you didn't do it all at once there
was a triumphant you know yeah
eventually these guys fell out and then
you know Caesar himself like takes
complete power but not complete power
because didn't keep them from getting a
dagger from Brutus and then you know
there's a lot of disorders after that
and then the new cabal comes to power
with with Augustus and Pompey was of
Crassus processes with Caesar anything
right in any case there's a lot of
disturbances going on politically what
cicero did and we're a lot of people in
his class this was for the moment he
didn't want a unified - regime he wanted
you know everybody to be participating
top cross he retired to his Villa and he
started writing philosophy we started
writing these these books that you know
you notice I've got this little red book
here this is the low classic series this
is the sister with the Latin amounting
wish on opposite pages and so you know
this is if you're a Cicero scholar you
get yourself these things I didn't get a
little shelf of them because he wrote a
ton of stuff now what he wrote was not
particularly original she wasn't trying
to create a new philosophy himself and
this is part of what actually makes
Cicero so interesting and so valuable
she thought there were enough people out
there who were already really smart
who'd already you know debated these
issues and what was his job to sort of
bring them together and see if you can
get them to argue with each other to
make their case to each other
and so he knew each of these schools
really well and he could say well if
somebody was a stoic they would say this
if somebody was an epicurean they would
say this this is the kind of arguments
that they make here's the criticisms
that they make of their opponents let me
just bring these together and book after
book lesson about different topics and
he would switch up the cast so if it was
something he's got a book for example
about a fate and in that the Stoics are
really the big target so you got a stoic
talking but then you know you have some
other people talking in this one it's
about the nature of the gods and so he's
got these these guys talking and you'll
see why it was just a few minutes so
when Cicero did is he tried to produce
something like an encyclopedia
philosophy but an encyclopedia that
would be in dialogue now why do you
think he wrote in dialogue form if you
had to speculate why not just like you
know do it encyclopedia with entries you
guys are all used to like you know
Britannica
whatever whatever Wikipedia entries for
everything which PDF dialogue form the
certain extent because people you know
yab their bit you know like it's taken
out but why does he keep wrote dialogues
that just yeah yeah there's that's an
important element he wants we saw this
with a play play believes some gaps
where you could actually say yeah but
what about and he does that I think
deliberately Cicero is doing something
kind of like that as well is there any
other reason though
why okay yeah you know there was a
long-standing tradition of writing
dialogues Aristotle wrote dialogues
which we don't have unfortunately they
lost a lot of other people so there is
that but why why do you think he did
that to show that it's any more people
can kind of see a unification from the
learning that
okay yeah he doesn't actually try to
replicate the style and he talks about
the Epicureans for example not having
any style that's an element of them
you're getting towards allow those
things to be personified and things like
this hit home with us better when we can
actually attach them to a person it's
easier to remember it's easier to keep
in mind when it's not just you know
stoic said but actually cop who's saying
this about the stoic so maybe he got it
right we're gonna ball this the stoic
actually talks and they get pretty
excited don't they these guys that you
can convey in a dialogue you have to
struggle a little bit to get it through
the addiction and all that but then you
can convene in a dialogue and you can't
really do it in a philosophical text
that's more like a treatise or text
so let's let's talk a little bit about
these guys who he's bringing up and
we'll talk about their philosophical
schools this is happening at cottage
house
Cicero goes next door socata is his
neighbor and he says cata says hey I'm
glad you're here we're in the middle of
an argument a debate you can you know
join in and I'll be happy because you're
actually you know on my side you belong
to my school
Cicero leaned more towards the academic
school at least on things like like this
in other things he adopted thinking the
Stoics ramires Italians but in this this
debate at least about the nature of the
gods he would be an ally to the Cicero
actually help cop out at all does he say
anything after that not a thing
Cadiz at his own the sister will go babe
I don't you dread all the way to the end
of the dialogue the Cicero go away agree
with tada I never remember what happens
he says I went away thinking all of us
actually it was probably more right so
sister was willing to change his mind so
who are these guys tada
is a member what's this academic school
our art hall school's academic after all
yeah well we get that you know the term
remember who who founded the Academy
remember off you talk about this a
little bit earlier this semester
there are some fun of Alexia who founded
the Academy yeah plate yeah he actually
made a school in Athens that was a new
thing people that in Hanna in actual
schools and he taught lessons and
according to Plato at that time you had
first learned geometry before he'd let
you into study philosophy because
geometry trained you to be able to
contemplate the forms and stuff like
that now the Academy had been around for
quite a while you notice that it's you
know best students didn't get to be the
next guy Aristotle had to go off and
found his own school in Park as he got
passed over which will often happens in
business as know or in academic affairs
or any sort of organization who do you
think got the job after Plato
it wasn't Aristotle his best student who
else had some disagreements with them
who would you expect
just imagine businesses that you've
worked for Socrates is dead Larry he's
he's Plato's teacher so it can't be him
who would you suspect it might be it's
not the most talented person then yeah
yeah somebody who has connections
actually turns out to be his nephew it
spells impass and specifics wasn't a
dumb guy but he wasn't aristotle
calendar and then you know there's a
bunch of generations after that they
actually created a handout that I put in
I learned for you that unless you see
you know these schools at least up until
the time the Cicero they alternate from
Socrates except for the epicurean spawn
so the Academy is coming from Socrates
through Plato and at a certain point the
transition to what we call the middle
Academy takes place at first they were
all plaintiffs right so what would you
expect them to believe them the dwarves
doctor of recollection those things that
I've had you guys look at before now
Socrates if you think back to the Meno
and if you if you read some other
dialogues you would see Socrates saying
things like well we don't really know
anything we're not even really quite
knowledge is we just don't know that we
have we know that we don't have think
about you know did they define virtue of
the Meno
did they ever succeed in that yeah in
his apology which is a speech that he
gives before the Athenian assembly where
they're gonna try for capital crimes he
says he gives me it tells a little story
about himself and he says this friend of
mine went to the Oracle and he asked
whether Socrates is the wisest man in
Greece the Oracle said yes nicely that
doesn't make any sense
because I'm not wise I don't really know
an awful lot and so I went around they
asked all sorts of people all sorts of
questions sort of like you did with vino
and turned out they didn't actually know
anything either ask the politicians
turns out they don't know what they're
doing as the poet's turns out what they
do is just by divine inspiration I asked
the craftspeople they at least knew
their craft but then they didn't know
anything outside of that and you know
why I'm so wise because I realized I
don't know anything because I'm not
handicapped by thinking that I actually
know what I'm doing or I know this this
subject remember back to when chakras
you know got criticized for being the
Stingray and stomach people that's
that's him letting them know that they
don't know things so the Academy the
middle Academy can seized on that if you
had to talk about that point of view and
what is another word you can call it
being a skeptic being a skeptic doesn't
mean just being a you know a pain in the
rear and bothering people with with
questions all the time it means saying
I'm not really sure about this I don't
really know what the answer is I may
know that this isn't the answer and
that's not the answer but I don't
actually have the answer I'm looking for
the answer
skeptic comes from the word to seek to
seek out the answer so that's what kata
is doing you notice kata is not really
good at telling you what he actually
does think he's great at telling you
what's wrong with what you think of why
there's a good chance that could be
false and what other people think about
the same things but he never actually
comes forward and says here's exactly
what I think and that's what his school
would do they would argue both sides of
a question or multiple sites of question
they were critical
they were analyzing other people's party
that's because they thought well if you
actually have a good reason the county
should be able to hold up to dialectical
scrutiny you know if it doesn't then
then we're actually you know better off
not buying into something that we don't
we're not actually sure and you know if
you're talking about the gods how much
do we really know about the guys or or
God or divinity or stuff like that
so we'll get to that in a moment peleus
cuz I never remember what school he
belongs to give your trust you either
have a carrion or start is it out the
curator so what we do with that word
these days
if you're an epicurean if I call you an
epicurean is it a bad term a good term
neutral term what does it refer to these
days you've heard this right once in a
while we get the end it's got something
to do with that that other college ran
through yeah an epicurean is somebody
who really likes food rank takes a lot
of pleasure in it they might be a cook
themselves they're certainly a
connoisseur of good food and wine and
then whatever else are you you're like
that's what it's come to mean for us and
the reason it's come to mean that for us
is because the epicurean school in
ethics said that pleasure is the good
and you know why do you eat fancy food
why would you go up you know and shell
out good money at the culinary to sit in
a fancy restaurant and have these you
know chefs and training serving you all
this this frankly you know sometimes
quite weird stuff because the taste
group because it looks great because
there's experience that's what we've
come to narrow it down to but think
about the whole other range of pleasures
right what else do you guys find
pleasurable
drinking yeah music is the big thing
it's interesting to carry like whole
library of music around that that the
ancients would have done just totally
Java yeah yeah sports and hobbies okay
we take pleasure to those I'm gonna do
the paint out sports to hopefully we get
some pleasure too
what else reading learning believe it or
not there are people who you know not
not your age usually but people who are
much older who take classes solely for
pleasure I know I miss actually being in
classes it's nicer being a student than
being a professor in a lot of respects
kind of miss actually getting to sit
back and hear somebody else talk for a
while yeah they're the whole range of
pleasures
those are understood as being good for
me on the curators I'll talk a little
bit more about the other parts of their
philosophy well let's talk about all
this now so what does he belong to
he's what he's the guy who runs the
storage the Stoics themselves traced
back to socrates the Epicureans don't
they traced back to Epicurus and
Epicurus got some of his ideas from
Democritus who was not connected with
Socrates and I'm not going to go into
any great detail about what he got from
Democritus was this notion that
everything is made of atoms continuously
falling and avoid and every once in a
while they swerve into each other and
connect up and that's what you're
looking at right here like you know that
person right there and the desk that
she's sitting in are just a bunch of
atoms arranged in different ways how is
she different than that guy you know
different atoms arranged in different
ways and presumably if we took you know
some of your atoms and you know mixed up
with some of her atoms you know
we did like maybe put your head on her
body and work or something that's the
second of science fiction things that we
do in cartoons because it's all just
animals it's all just you know compounds
of those things
the Stoics had a very different view
they were materialists they thought
everything was a type of body including
the soul but they they thought things
were up to chance
like I said they they come from Socrates
here's here's the way they come from
Socrates Socrates said a student call
dentist amis who founds the cynic school
and that goes on for a while when
there's a gagging krottas who teaches a
gagging Zeno who also studies under a
guy named still though it was from
another Socratic school and so you know
kind of mixes these things together and
starts his own philosophical stool which
school which is called the stoic school
from stoah which is the porch
he'd lecture out of porch they were the
porch talkers so that's that's the word
of this school it was a great school
like I said they were materialist they
thought however that there was some sort
of reason or mind or soul that pervaded
everything they also fought something
very different about the good then did
the Epicureans the epicurean stuff is
player and everything else you know we
desire for the sake of pleasure
the Stoics thought that the good is
virtue and freedoms and that pleasure is
generally to be distrusted because
pleasure tends to get you in trouble
it tends to ensnare you really what you
want is to be completely rational and
free and only occupy yourself with those
sorts of things they thought that the
gods actually really cared about human
being
the curious lot guys don't care about
computers so already you've got some big
differences there why would the
Epicureans think the guys don't care
about human beings gods are blessed you
know what is it likely to care about
somebody is it
finding games all the time there's a
pleasure all the time it's a pain just
wait till you have kids then you know
you know care about all sorts of things
that you you didn't care about at all
before and that are gonna bug you so the
gods you know they're really going to be
blessed they can't have any connection
with the world human beings they can't
make things work the Epicureans think
the gods are or God is active pervading
everything providing guidance even down
to the level of you know like divination
prophecies that's right so some very
different conceptions divinity these
guys are going to square off against
each other and the general structure of
the book is is like this there's again a
little meet-and-greet at the beginning
and then the last is going to talk and
what's the way it's going to do
he's an epicurean so what would you
expect him to do well it doesn't say
that they're actually eating or drinking
anything in this case this is a long
discussion he happened without any sort
of drinks and what is he gonna do with
its pocket if he's an epicurean what do
you imagine
man your let me put it to this you are
put onto the camera it's some sort of
discussion and you represent some some
school of thought that's very different
than the other people on the panel it's
your turn to talk
what are you gonna do
yeah that's a good idea I mean nowadays
especially you know TV and sound bites
you better have something quick to start
out with you know some nice formulation
you're going to state your view you're
going to try to make a case for how do
you make a case for your view when you
have rival views is it enough just to
state your view yeah I think you're
right you would actually tell them why
their views are wrong if you think that
your views is for the right views and
they're different from these other
people's views then they're blocking us
so reason why their views are actually
long your honor there are to be some
reason why they're mistaken what they
think is is correct and you'd actually
be doing them a favor by exposing that
that's not to them you know providing
not doing an abusive way hey you're so
stupid because you know that sort of
thing or just engaging trickery but if
you really think that your views are
right makes sense to tell other people
what their views are wrong that's what
Malaya sucks he actually starts out by
doing two different criticisms he
criticizes all the philosophers like all
the way down to Plato and Aristotle and
then he says and now you Stoics you also
have these crazy views that can't
possibly be correct
and then after that he tells what what
his own position is and he tries to
provide some some reasons for believing
in his position so in book one that's
what's going on mostly the hind end of
book one is kata coming in and then
trying to do the same thing trying to
say to the lands the stuff that you're
arguing you don't actually have any good
basis for and this is what a skeptic
would do they would you know attacked
other people
to do other people's arguments that's
what's going on in book 1 book 2 is
almost all Balthus talking and
presenting the stud with you and he
presents arguments as well and it gets
pretty involved pretty pretty detailed
as a matter of fact so that I actually
cut out of the text that I forgot of you
because because it doesn't these
long-winded discourses about you know
poets and this camp and historic you
know like and I thought maybe you'd find
something that can't form if you want to
read the whole text I'm glad you can
book three it goes back to kata and now
kata is criticizing the Stoics point of
view and giving me a little bit of his
own point of view so that's the basic
structure of the work so today and what
we have left we're going to look at what
this guy's saying and that's some of the
responses if we have time that the kata
is making time so let's let's think
about the criticisms that the Epicureans
are making so you've got these
criticisms of everybody from saleh's
ceramics address all the way down to
Plato and Aristotle and they basically
boil down to this this guy thinks this
thing is God
this other guy thinks this thing is God
this guy thinks this thing is God all
these things that they think are
confusing I don't know
doesn't seem to make sense why they
would they would consider this thing to
be God it seems like they're just sort
of pulling things out of the air it
doesn't make there's no intrinsic
necessity for you know whatever mind do
they think is out there where did that
come from how did that take place
we're not explaining things accurately
when it comes to the Stoics it gets a
little bit more
and he actually looks at some of the
beliefs of the stocks yeah what were
some of the things that Stoics believed
well some of the stomachs said that God
was actually the natural law that that
pervades all things or a rationality
that's in everything whether it's this
podium myself you the world as a whole
something tying us all together there's
a man through some like some essence
pervading the entire universe that's God
or maybe it's the entire universe itself
understood as having a soul maybe that's
God or maybe it's and he goes on with a
number of other things maybe it is
Providence or fate
maybe it's human beings that have been
defied and made into God and so the
trouble is you Stoics is what he's
saying you still accept all these
different ideas and they they don't you
can't possibly hold all these at the
same time which of these is God I mean
do you believe in God or the gods you
guys have to like pin it down and until
you do we shouldn't we shouldn't believe
you see that would be a you know that
would be a reasonable thing to say to
somebody if you were in a debate with
somebody you could say them what you've
got all these ideas and they sound like
interesting ideas but they don't they
don't fit together and then the other
person you know they really haven't
thought through it presumably say yeah
maybe I got a pick and choose among his
ideas so those are some of the
criticisms in today one of the criticism
that he's making is really interesting
and it has to do with a metaphysical
issue
now how do we generally think of time
and linear NASA Dana because there's an
alternation right wouldn't be bilinear
the time is always progressing in one
direction we can never alter the
direction of flow of time okay yeah you
tell them think of things we go from the
past to the future and you know like
here's the present right now nope now
it's here Alex here now it's here no
keeps on going on and on right and what
is history
well history is like you're not talking
about this what happened this time and
then if you buy the book before that you
have this time and maybe you know
there's another book before that yeah
this time that's a periods of time right
you've always got time don't you now if
you want to say like Plato does in a
dialogue that I haven't can you guys
read but you could read come to mass or
if you want to say like the stomachs do
that there is a creation but the world
the whole universe gets created by some
sort of mind that has to happen at some
point of time right now who does the
creating in this case
and then once about the creation no
problem
creation has been created keeps going on
the universe is there does all sorts of
neat things time keeps rolling on but
here's the problem there was a time
before the creation so what were these
God's doing or what was God doing before
that was he just sitting around sleeping
was just taking it easy because you
don't want to wear himself out these are
these are some of the suggestions that
are being made here's the problem if you
have passed before the creation you got
to be able to come up with some sort of
account why it was that God did this at
this point in time rather than say here
or why not here what was he doing this
whole time or again who are she or
whatever you want to conceive of God is
being this is a real deep metaphysical
problem and so you know I'm just and
will consider this later on he'll
actually talk about this in a book that
you're not going to read in this class
of confessions and he says kind of
jokingly what was God doing for creating
the universe and he says creating health
for people who asked questions like that
all right
jokes aside ll talk about you know what
he was actually doing st. Augustine's
the answer is actually there isn't any
time before the creation of universe
because what is time time is change in
the universe but if you conceive of time
as being something independent of the
universe as existing before that then
you got this problem of explaining what
was God doing all that time why didn't
he act before that and Epicurus are the
Epicureans are bringing this up as a
real you know problem for anybody who
believes in sort of a traditional
conception
God is being creative all-powerful you
know creating the universe out of
nothing some sort of seeds or something
like that maybe that is a real issue how
do we often tend to think about this we
don't really think about so much in
terms of God people ask questions about
what would be this special point for us
in physics the Big Bang right and then
people say what was what was happening
before the Big Bang and then was the
scientists daily nothing nothing was
happening there wasn't any time to be
happening before yet before the
singularity so you know what you'd have
to say is I'm sorry it's like this this
is a deep metaphysical issue and we're
not gonna try to resolve this today I'm
just saying there's different models of
us but he's touching on something very
deep yeah strongly against the by taking
grief Oh
cyclical time yeah because even then
their gods even in their own mythology
did not come first
yeah they were created from other beings
which were created from other beings
yeah in in some of the poetic works it's
you know chaos which is first you know
something like that and then and then
you know literally us guys like who are
those which means just means sky
and then only later on do you get
through that the advances yeah the
Stoics thought of actually there being
like the governors is this sort of you
know mind pervading everything and that
line was actually fired and everything
gets resolved into you know Universal
fire at the end of things and then that
sort of blossoms forth and
all these things that we experience they
get really easy about this and what's
they're really doing for me Houston
verifier well it's it's yeah they did it
to allegorize to they tended to see a
lot of these myths as just sort of
expressing Kennedy Hall not that literal
truths but particular tetras that was
the Stoics the Epicureans didn't think
they had a problem with this because
their dads aren't creative see for the
other curious cops don't do anything you
know what's most fundamental for the
Epicureans right
Adams falling in the void and hooking up
with each other
the gods are made of the atoms the whole
universe is made of atoms and you don't
have to worry about that some sort of
creative mind arranging things and
making things mad or making them out
nothing because the gods don't care
about this work this is only a problem
for people like you know the Stoics or
Plato whose got a divine craftsman or
for Christians and Jews so they you know
if you if you start with this but if you
like like Augustine does the problem
what if you allow there to be time
backwards behind it
then you've got no problem then you
gotta figure what was God doing all of
all that time so that's an interesting
criticism
let's look now at some of the stuff with
the Epicureans are actually standing so
what is the latest tell us about the the
gods
whether they exist or whether they they
do exist both let's think about this
this notion sort of the Gods being their
existing but not being involved with
things what would that do to a religious
point of view like like that of the
ancient race what if ancient Greeks do
with the guys just writing like pictures
of our statues what's that idle eyes
them what does that mean idolize that it
makes statues but what would they do
with those statutes that's what a very
high-minded conception religion consists
a lot of ritual
what kind of yeah say they kind of bring
offerings and when it comes time for the
harvest or your fishing village they
even bringing offerings to God so yeah
who the snow is niche on Kahler yeah I
mean some of them you know you read The
Odyssey they sacrifice Hecate songs that
means 100 cannon that's a lot meat and
you know the priest to beat some of the
meat and some of it get burned up you
know for the for the gods the idea was
it goes off of me
somehow consumed a very materialistic
conception Danny
in that case and now if you're an
epicurean and you said of gods they
don't care about that sort of stuff you
wouldn't do a sacrifice would you save
your money
they also get to make offerings in the
temple you got saved at sea because you
pray to the side will you buy a little
gold statue to put it in the temple you
give something
would you pray if you had a consent
the gods is being enacted it will be the
point gods don't care about prayers
they're just up there somewhere but
they're not they're not doing anything
what about you know fortune-telling or
prophecies or stuff like that well
they're probably two people making stuff
up you can't rely on any of that because
again the gods don't reveal anything to
us there's another thing to this to
Epicurus thought this is a real good
advance if the gods don't care about
human beings what are some of the
emotions they won't feel towards this
walk right that's not good it'd be nice
to have somebody love us upstairs
wouldn't it but there's a flipside of
this if they don't love you then what
else don't they do they don't hate you
like decidedly hated Odysseus for
counting out his sons I what else don't
they
what are some human emotions that you
you got watch it when somebody feels
those toys here what's up anything
present and although God's probably
can't be that resentful because we're
usually resentful this one who pushes us
down well what else what's close to
resentment what's up anger yeah the
guy's you know there's a lot of worry
about hearing God's jealousy too
maybe the guys to get jealous of human
beings and the ancient Greek stories
sometimes they did so Lucretius now the
creatures feasel later about the carrion
Epicurus said look the cops don't care
about anything we don't have to live in
fear them we don't have to worry about
their anger we just have to do you know
the sort of things that we need to do
for ourselves and we can look up to the
gods we can idolize them in that sense
we can say I'd like to be like them
totally detached just enjoying myself
stay out of politics that's
Epicureans who do you know just have
some friends and make sure your friends
are not the kind of people to irritate
you
that's the way the consulate you want to
be like that we're not afraid to them
because they can't actually help us out
all they can do is provide us a good
example now he actually makes an
argument you might said why is he doing
this I get that the moment he makes an
argument for the existence and this is
typically called the arguments from and
the rings of the argument from common
consent codes and it's not just will ASU
makes us there's a lot of people who've
made this throughout history they say
well if you look around at everybody
everybody's got some conception of God
something they worship and you know I
understand this would be a problem for
modern times there's a lot of atheists
out there right and their whole
societies that are officially atheist
like is it kind of just China you know
North Korea actually has its own weird
kind of state religion which is
basically a cult of personality so it
wouldn't qualify as being totally hate
yes but you get the idea
because well I'd say they actually have
a very religious point of view it just
happens to be the state and the leader
that's that's made it to those objects
even mainland China does not totally
devoid of religion I don't know if I
brought up in this class or another
class one of the things that the state
has been struggling with for like the
last 20 years our taxi drivers and other
drivers putting little images of
Chairman Mao in their taxis with the
belief that he is a is like a
traditional Chinese God and will protect
them from accidents which are very
common Chinese traffic but let's just go
with where the ancient Greeks were look
around in all the different societies
they'll had religious didn't thing they
differed on the religion right might be
they prayed Osiris and you know Horus
and Isis rather than praying to Demeter
and Zeus and Hercules or something like
that what are our orders
what's up the North's Norse goddess who
the Norse gods right they didn't know
the course at that time but yeah they
could have you know imagine it's
traveling around the world right
everywhere you go you'd find some sort
of something people worshipped so there
is some common idea that people have of
divinity and what does this prove this
proves that there are gods
because nobody's making them have this
idea it's not that the state is coming
in and saying you will all practice
religion that comes later on all of
these different cultures arrive at some
sort of notion of there being something
higher than human beings to worship on
their own independently of each other
after a while when they get to know each
other
you know affect each other I kind of
like that ritual they have over there
let's take that out you know let's do
that but in the you know the origins
each one of these religions each one of
these societies is doing its own thing
now how could they possibly be doing
that if it didn't actually correspond to
something real this seems to be
something almost you know remember we
talked about properties when we talked
about Aristotle this is a property of
human beings that they are the religious
animal now well extra let me let me
introduce one more wrinkle before we
start looking at you know how this could
go wrong with the Epicureans they have
this notion of a if they're in
philosophy degree before this is
prolapses which means literally lays the
latest is coming from lamagno which
means from embodiments a grasp to pull
it for yourself Pro you know that means
before right so these are general ideas
that human beings are kind of born with
they're hardwired into our very being
our minds and we use them to make sense
of the things they're not they're not
photonic forms because they're gonna our
hats and we use them to make sense of
the things that we experience so all
human beings according to the Epicureans
have some sort of common conception of
God
so therefore God must exist do you see
any problems with us in any ways this
might not be completely airtight this is
actually the weakest
yeah like invented something doesn't
mean that's real that's a big problem
this then yeah I mean and then they talk
about centaurs right and none of these
guys believe centaurs are real even
though the poet's have talked about them
every time the referencing some tourism
they're they're using that as a purely
imaginary ah how do we how do people
make that well you take like you know
torso of a guy take a horse kind of set
up and just plop it on there in your
head and there you go you got a centaur
now you can make them do all sorts of
things like you know trance around shoot
arrows and you know betrayed Hercules
teach teach Achilles whatever you like
that doesn't mean that that's
necessarily real spread to other places
conscience it's so historic that could
have been some kind of origin that
that's an interesting idea I mean it
would have to be really really early on
like before mankind diffused all across
the world because we see these different
things arise and more or less
independent affecting each other yeah
you could like show that there was some
common like you know our ancestors who
marched out of the Africa into the
Middle East Asia and Europe across the
Bering Straits all that somehow
if you could show that that those
hominids actually make sense and again
you could also say well it doesn't mean
that it's real just because they any
other problems yeah you know when it
comes to questions about the gods you're
never gonna have physical evidence in
the sense you would like you know if I
say to you don't eat the choc you're not
gonna like the way it tastes and say I
have to prove this courage of myself
when you start munching on anyway yeah
that doesn't taste good it's up that
sort of thing and that's what we had
philosophical arguments for the
existence of the guys because if it was
just as simple as looking around oh hey
there's this we wouldn't have any
debates right it's mad effective
Russians at one time we're kind of
goofing around when they first did their
their first manned space flight one of
their compliments that I looked around
but I didn't see any angels there for
the Christians are wrong about that you
wouldn't see angels floating around in
outer space that's not what Christians
actually believe you know people have
that that's right
there are some other problems with this
gender and perception of what
it's like a lot of people replace it on
a physical being cooler for somebody
else it could be that you know a dear to
them so the fact that there's
divergences right okay yeah work work
that's a good point we'll get to that in
just one second socata raises some some
problems in something he says look what
one problem is not everybody doesn't do
the guys you know there are some people
who may actually assert the gods don't
exist there's atheists there's there's
agnostics there's also people that are
like practical atheists because of these
the MPs these are people who say that
they believe in religion but then they
act like they don't believe it and so
you know can you really say that they
actually believe in that case if we all
have a common preconception sort of
woven into our being then there should
be an atheist right according to that
but you know maybe you can get around
that by saying wow those people are
mistake and they're not paying
attentions of rican sections they're the
perverse they says if we actually look
at human cultures though we have a
problem because now the Greeks knew a
lot and the Romans been a lot of
different cultures some of the cultures
that they knew they thought were really
barbarous really savage and they thought
that these cultures that actually turns
out they're they're wrong about this
historically they thought these cultures
don't actually have a conception of the
Gods they may have some sort of vague
nature based you know views on you know
higher powers or something like that the
animals that's not yet notions with the
gods so that would be a problem because
there would be a different preconception
and then he says even granting that if
we do look at these different cultures
they all have some sort of religious on
consent
here's where we at this point is it
really a sheer consumption how do they
think about the guys I mean if you think
God is a deer that seems to be a very
different conception of God being some
sort of human-like creature up in heaven
calling the shots those are are those
really the same notion I don't know
that's where it gets pretty pretty weak
it doesn't seem like this is one of the
weaknesses of the argument your company
so it doesn't seem like everybody is on
the same and that's not the case you're
not going to get the whole argues that
started even if you do the mere fact
that everybody believes in it does that
actually make it true
are there other things that human beings
for a long time everybody believed in
would turn out to be false earth was the
center of the universe that's a big one
yeah you know the ancient Greeks the
philosophical ones they knew that the
world is round and they knew this is the
Middle Ages tokens good the same en song
just mentions it a lot handily so as we
all know the world wrong maybe everybody
who's intelligent so this notion that it
could be thought the earth is flat not
true but they did all think it was in
the center of the universe they did all
think that wherever it happened to be
that was it and everything else you know
wasn't around yet it's not the case and
not to be the case yeah so there's you
know there's some things that we can't
believe did and just because everybody
has a belief about it that doesn't
and make it correct this is a pretty
weak argument but people do make it even
down to the present day there's another
part to this argument not not being used
to talking about the existence of God to
talk about the nature of God that voice
brings up as well he says that the gods
must have a form similar to human beings
now think about this really do you
believe in God would you like God to
look like a human being where would you
like God to look like an alien
or a deer or what else you know
whirling discs of fire pick whatever
yellow why would you like that common
ground between the defining yeah you
could relate to that kind of guy
well I mean you know you're a Christian
that you do think that God took human
form yeah you know Scott Jesus wandered
around got himself killed at about
thirty five to thirty thirty four thirty
33 years old
you know after talking a lot and doing
some miracles and you know traditional
Christian doctrine talked about being
able to relate to God because God was
like human beings and the Greeks you
know they they conceived the gods to be
more or less sort of like super human
beings you know Zeus has arms and legs
and then you know you could make a
statue of them with a long beard and
looking a bit middle-aged but still
really tough and buff because he had a
more or less uniform
now the Epicureans are saying that's
what the gods are like and he gives a
couple of arguments for them so he says
look human beings have a common
preconception of gods like that go
around look at the different religions
that's how you got we see God depicted
God have a human form and then he also
says to other things that are really
interesting
he says the human form is the most
beautiful category it's the most well
adapted I think about this I mean we do
have a few people that are kind of weird
fetishes who who think that the animals
are more attractive than the human
beings and sometimes they do
do they support of walk but most of us
think human beings are our most
attractive right we're attracted to
human beings not to call force not to to
lampposts right to human beings we think
human beings are the most beautiful most
attractive
well the gods are going to have the most
beautiful former I think so it's got to
be a dimming form that's an argument and
then the other thing that he says it's
really interesting only the human form
can contain intelligence they got let's
look around you know
dolphins are pretty smart I don't see
dolphins making iPhones or making calls
on iPhones we do you know what else are
pretty smart chimpanzees gorillas every
smart too
not smart enough to keep themselves from
getting wiped out though apparently how
smart is less you know we could run
through the whole list octopi are just
the invertebrate Kingdom are like the
geniuses they can they can do things
like figure out complex puzzles if they
if they live more than than you know
four or five years we'd probably be in
trouble evolutionarily they don't they
haven't developed technology yet so
we're okay
human beings seem to be the only
rational animals
gods are rational gods must have human
form so these are the arguments that
that Peleus is making about that kata
criticizes these so that's where rule
actually the 11 let's look at these
criticisms is the human form really the
most beautiful form that's a good
question to ask yourself good thing to
think about what what is it that makes
the human form the most beautiful
is the case this is a human form really
that beautiful if you read through the
stuff that kind of sense of mode he
brings up people with pimples and you
know misshapen people you know we
actually go around we look at real human
beings all right they all you know meet
this this perfect standard think about
celebrity so if anything guys ever like
like that these pictures of celebrities
about makeup some of them are ugly right
there yeah Wow
whoever it gets paid to do the makeup
job that person they're really earning
their money cuz because I can like walk
down the street and find ten people way
more attractive than this this person
you know so maybe maybe our form really
isn't that attractive he brings up
another worried too maybe the reason why
we feel that the human form is the most
attractive is because every single
animal by its nature finds its own for
most attractive dogs don't you know go
and you know poor cats do they not most
dogs I've never seen it talked to do
that doesn't that doesn't work dogs go
to find other dogs they like other dogs
cats gonna find other cats
there you go down the list right then we
have to go any further with this and you
see where this is going so maybe the
only reason why we think our form is so
attractive is because we like is it
really the case that we all have some
sort of common conception of the gods as
being human like is that true in all
cultures you think of any cultures where
the gods are something different
Egyptians yeah the Egyptians they that's
who they've mentioned in here the
Egyptians said that a bull was those
guys gave us the concept they have
generally had like the animal heads on
right you can say well they're still
human you know because they got harvest
legs any other cultures that have gods
that we're into us yeah you don't even
like it Nash with the elephant oh yeah
yeah that's you know I never thought
that's a good point
Shiva now you know why he has a lot of
artists because arms represent power
more in India you know sort of
iconography more arms you got the more
powerful they are so if you got you know
forearms that's good you got a terms
that seems better
one hundred dollars a pop you're
superdad
and the other cultures that have a
nonhuman yeah if coyote is a trickster
god okay who does a coyote right it's
well there you go Wolverine yeah there's
there's some issues about that we don't
really have a common preconception that
would make God have human form even if
it gods exist
what about rationality if we look around
at the animals that we know we are
maybe dolphins are kind of rational
maybe chimpanzees are if any of your
animal behaviorists does that mean that
only a human form could contain
rationality
I mean we're experimenting right now
yeah I'm not not saying they actually
could do this with an iPhone itself
we're experimenting with artificial
intelligence are trying to create
rationality and something that would be
just circuits we didn't create a lot of
things that seem like rationality that's
one Avenue to go on could we imagine you
know some creature that didn't have to
even form that was rational